[MUSIC PLAYING]
EMILY FORTUNA: Hello, and
welcome to "The Boring Show."
I'm Emily Fortuna,
again, and with us
is a very special guest.
LARA MARTIN: I'm Lara Martin.
I am a [INAUDIBLE] developer
specialized on Android,
working in a very, very small
company in Berlin, Germany.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yeah.
I'm so glad to have
you with us today.
LARA MARTIN: Thank you.
EMILY FORTUNA: As you
can see, our setup
is a little different.
And that's because we're not
shooting in our normal studio.
This is "Boring
Show" on the road.
[LAUGHS] Lara was giving
a presentation with me,
and so we figured we would shoot
a super special episode here
today.
So today, what
we're hoping to do
is we're going to
talk a little bit
about the Flutter, inspector
and how it can be used.
I think it's a
under-appreciated feature.
And then, as promised,
we will get back to,
on the Hacker News app, how
to implement keeping the page
scroll position.
And we'll be doing a
little bit of refactoring
with that, as well.
So Lara, let's take a
look at Flutter Inspector.
LARA MARTIN: Sure.
OK, right now I have
the project running.
I'm going to close this.
And we should be able to see
exactly the widget tree we
have displayed on our emulator.
OK, we're going to
refresh, just in case.
EMILY FORTUNA: Sure.
LARA MARTIN: OK,
everything is good.
So what do we have here?
Do you want to see the
widget tree, or options, or--
EMILY FORTUNA: Give me a tour.
Tell me [INAUDIBLE]
LARA MARTIN: OK.
EMILY FORTUNA: Show me what
you think is [INAUDIBLE] first.
LARA MARTIN: So
the first thing you
see when you open the Flutter
Inspector is basically
the widget tree that you
have on your app running.
So here, we see that
we have a MaterialApp,
we have our MyHomePage--
EMILY FORTUNA: Very
exciting right there.
LARA MARTIN: Yeah, yeah.
And a Scaffold.
Surprise, right?
And we see a bunch
of other widgets.
EMILY FORTUNA: All the articles.
LARA MARTIN: Exactly.
They're the same.
So I really like these.
So we can get to sometimes
see bugs, something
that is strange on the screen.
EMILY FORTUNA: Mm-hmm.
LARA MARTIN: And you can--
I think it's tapping
on this icon here.
EMILY FORTUNA: Oh,
it highlights--
LARA MARTIN: You can
basically select something.
Like ListView,
what's the ListView?
EMILY FORTUNA: Where is it?
LARA MARTIN: Yeah.
In the beginning, I didn't
understand what was a scaffold,
or what was exactly.
EMILY FORTUNA: And you're
like, it's a whole thing.
LARA MARTIN: It's a whole thing.
EMILY FORTUNA: I'm so confused.
LARA MARTIN: Yeah.
Straightforward.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yeah.
So in case you're still
confused about the scaffold,
it's basically sort
of an outline--
it's providing
scaffolding, if that's
kind of an unusual word to use.
It's basically
providing structure
for where different things
are laid out in your app
on the overall screen.
So it tells you that the
app bar should be up on top.
And your body should
be the main part, and--
LARA MARTIN: Exactly.
EMILY FORTUNA:
--that sort of thing.
LARA MARTIN: If we
collapse things,
we can see that we have
basically three parts.
The body, this part.
And then we have the app bar on
top, and the bottom navigation.
EMILY FORTUNA: Cool.
LARA MARTIN: Yeah.
That's really cool when you
don't know what a widget is.
Let's say, I don't
know exactly what's
this square I'm seeing on the
screen, and you tap on it,
and you can divide it.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yeah.
LARA MARTIN: Because you
see what it's been rendered.
EMILY FORTUNA: So yeah.
I can imagine this
being super useful,
especially if you're
working with a code
base that is new to you.
LARA MARTIN: Yes.
EMILY FORTUNA:
And you're like, I
don't know how this is written,
where does this code live?
How can you tap on--
is there a mode that you need
to do to tap on the screen
so that it highlights
in the inspector?
LARA MARTIN: Yeah.
So basically, you
enable it by clicking
on this first icon, where it
says Toggle Select Widget Mode.
EMILY FORTUNA: OK, cool.
And then when you tap, it
will automatically [INAUDIBLE]
LARA MARTIN: Now it's off.
But if we turn it on,
then we can select things.
And for example, this one.
Or maybe, let's do--
do I want to lay an
icon on the app bar?
Maybe not.
Ah, because we are expanding.
Yeah, this is a bit
difficult, because where
we are expanding items.
EMILY FORTUNA: Is that a bug?
LARA MARTIN: Oh, it
changed the color, even.
EMILY FORTUNA:
What just happened?
[LAUGHS] Is that a
bug in the inspector?
Or do you think it's--
LARA MARTIN: I know.
We opened one of the items--
EMILY FORTUNA: Oh, we
opened the web view.
LARA MARTIN: Yeah.
EMILY FORTUNA: Oh, OK.
LARA MARTIN: Everything
is highlighted
in different colors.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yeah.
LARA MARTIN: Oh, OK.
But yeah.
Basically, you turn on,
and you can select items.
EMILY FORTUNA: And
so then over here--
LARA MARTIN: And then
you see, for example,
this item we have
highlighted, it just
stacks here in the tree.
And then you can see
more properties on it.
EMILY FORTUNA: Oh, cool.
Are they editable,
the properties?
Could you tweak things?
LARA MARTIN: Not
sure, to be honest.
I haven't tried yet.
EMILY FORTUNA: We could try now.
LARA MARTIN: Maybe we can.
EMILY FORTUNA: I guess
technically, with hot reload,
it's not super necessary,
but I'm just curious.
No.
LARA MARTIN: No.
EMILY FORTUNA: Oh, but you
could go to the source.
Click on that.
LARA MARTIN: Yeah.
That's very useful.
EMILY FORTUNA: And
then you can edit it.
LARA MARTIN: Also from here.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yeah, perfect.
LARA MARTIN: So you can
go to the source code,
and then go through it.
EMILY FORTUNA: Ah, nice.
That's super handy.
LARA MARTIN: Yeah.
EMILY FORTUNA: What are the
other buttons up on the Flutter
Inspector?
LARA MARTIN: Oh, wait.
I'm clicking things,
and [INAUDIBLE]
EMILY FORTUNA: Yeah, it
keeps jumping around.
LARA MARTIN: OK, let's go back.
Wait.
No.
So if you have to refresh,
because the [INAUDIBLE] you see
is not the same as the one on
the screen, you can refresh.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yeah.
So I guess that's probably--
I should talk to the
Flutter Inspector
creator, who sits nearby me,
but I haven't asked him--
I'm guessing that's
for performance reasons
that it doesn't
auto-update all the time.
LARA MARTIN: Exactly.
Yeah.
So I'm not sure this one.
Performance Overlay.
I didn't play with it yet much.
EMILY FORTUNA: So that is--
LARA MARTIN: I'm going
to disconnect this one.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yeah.
LARA MARTIN: Yeah.
So it will be, I guess, looking
at the performance of your app.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yeah.
And I know a little
bit about this one.
So it moves when you
are doing an animation,
because checking to see
that the animations are
in 60 frames per second.
And so, in this case, if
we're not moving anything,
the little bar there
is not doing anything.
LARA MARTIN: OK.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yeah.
I think if you scroll,
you'll see it go, too.
LARA MARTIN: OK.
EMILY FORTUNA: And
then one other thing
that I got a question
about earlier, and just
want to clarify.
So someone was complaining that
their app was not 60 frames
per second, very smooth.
And I was like, are you
running it in debug mode?
And they were like, what's that?
So what's going on is, when
you run your app normally
to develop so you can get hot
reload, it is in debug mode.
And you'll see there's a
banner at the top there
that says Debug.
LARA MARTIN: Debug.
EMILY FORTUNA: And so
to enable hot reload,
your performance is going
to be a little bit slower.
So testing this performance
overlay in debug mode
it's probably not the
most informative thing.
So if you want to
test performance,
you can run the release
version, and then you
can check the performance
overlay of that.
LARA MARTIN: Interesting.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yeah.
LARA MARTIN: So what
else do we have?
We have a button to
switch the platform.
EMILY FORTUNA: Oh, yeah.
LARA MARTIN: I
really like this one.
Right now, I'm running
an Android emulator,
so all the behaviors
are Android-like.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yeah.
LARA MARTIN: The
scrolling, and opening.
We should see this--
EMILY FORTUNA: It's
in the transition.
LARA MARTIN: Yeah, the
transition is the Android one.
So you see also the
title is on a side.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yes.
LARA MARTIN: But if
we enable the switch,
now I have an iOS simulator.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yes.
So this is super cool,
especially if you're developing
on, say, a Windows machine,
where you can't actually
set up iOS development,
but you want
to see what your app looks like.
LARA MARTIN: Yes.
EMILY FORTUNA: Just
toggle that button.
LARA MARTIN: Or you don't
have an iPhone, like me--
EMILY FORTUNA: Yeah.
LARA MARTIN: --and
you want to check out
how it's working on an iPhone.
EMILY FORTUNA: Well, you know,
you can set up a simulator.
LARA MARTIN: Yes.
Yes, I do have.
But it's to have
only one running.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yes.
Save yourself time.
Totally.
LARA MARTIN: And
then we basically can
see that the behavior
is iOS, basically.
We see the bouncing on the
[INAUDIBLE],, for example.
Transitions, iOS.
EMILY FORTUNA: Nice.
Very cool.
LARA MARTIN: Yes.
EMILY FORTUNA:
What else is there?
LARA MARTIN: And
then, what else?
This one is painting basically
the widgets you have,
the layout.
Like marking--
EMILY FORTUNA: Where they are?
LARA MARTIN: --the limits--
EMILY FORTUNA: Oh, OK.
LARA MARTIN:
--between the widgets.
In this case, we can see that
we have, for example, the logo
of the Hacker News.
It's making all the widgets
and the buttons around it.
EMILY FORTUNA: Got it.
LARA MARTIN: Like for
example, these lines,
I bet it means that we have
something that scrolls.
EMILY FORTUNA: I don't
know, that giant arrow.
LARA MARTIN: Yes.
And for example, that
these buttons are centered.
EMILY FORTUNA: Oh, OK.
LARA MARTIN: Well, the
icons and the text.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yeah.
LARA MARTIN: Yeah.
So it's also nice
to see sometimes.
To use this, I use it a lot
for developing Android--
EMILY FORTUNA: Oh, yeah?
LARA MARTIN: --for example.
Yes.
EMILY FORTUNA: How's
it useful for that?
LARA MARTIN: There's options
on developer's option
on the phone, that allows
you to see also the same.
The layout, it
highlights the views.
And it's very useful when you
have weird things happening
on your layout,
and you don't know
if there's a [INAUDIBLE] in some
place, a weird thing happening.
So this is really handy also.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yeah, totally.
LARA MARTIN: Yeah.
EMILY FORTUNA: Very cool.
LARA MARTIN: And then
we have two more icons,
but I honestly don't
know what they are.
EMILY FORTUNA: I don't
know, let's find out.
[LAUGHS]
LARA MARTIN: I
haven't tried them.
EMILY FORTUNA:
Experiment for everyone
LARA MARTIN: OK.
Show Paint Baselines.
[LAUGHS] The baselines
of the text, for example.
This is the baseline of the
text, and then the icons--
maybe because you want
to check if they are--
EMILY FORTUNA: Aligned?
LARA MARTIN: --aligned.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yeah.
For the typography
aficionados in the room.
LARA MARTIN: Yeah.
For those that say,
I think it's not--
EMILY FORTUNA: Yes--
LARA MARTIN:
--correctly aligned.
EMILY FORTUNA: So
don't have to do
what we did in our
presentation yesterday,
where we were looking at
our slides and we were like,
is this aligned?
And we literally had a paper.
LARA MARTIN: Yeah, we were
with a paper checking it.
It was an extra space.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yeah.
LARA MARTIN: I
think it's the same.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yeah.
I'll have to ask to see
if there's other features.
LARA MARTIN: Yeah.
I also have to read about it.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yeah.
OK.
Switch that.
LARA MARTIN: And
then the last one.
What is this?
Oh, slow animations.
EMILY FORTUNA: Oh, yes.
LARA MARTIN: So debug
your animations.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yes.
That is very nice.
Especially like--
so for example,
when Lara had clicked
in the Android mode,
and it transitioned
to the new page,
that one time it was so fast.
It was like, is
something [INAUDIBLE]??
I don't even know.
LARA MARTIN: We can do it now.
Now, I'm an iPhone.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yes.
LARA MARTIN: So we can
see the transition fast.
Let's go back.
And now, slow.
Oh, I think I tried it,
and it was very, very slow.
EMILY FORTUNA: So fun
fact, I accidentally
enabled that on my iPhone
emulator a while ago.
LARA MARTIN: Oh.
EMILY FORTUNA: And
I kept doing things,
and I thought my
app was bugging.
I was like, why is it so slow?
LARA MARTIN: Yeah.
EMILY FORTUNA: So yeah.
Beware, if you enable that, and
don't enable it all the time.
LARA MARTIN: But no worries,
that happens to everyone.
To me, it happened many
times that I was testing
the internet connection--
EMILY FORTUNA: Oh, gosh.
LARA MARTIN: --and
you put your emulator
on like, slow connection,
very slow connection.
And then for days, I'm like--
EMILY FORTUNA: Why
is this horrible?
LARA MARTIN: --this
is very slow.
What's happening on my internet?
And then I ask my
friends, my colleagues,
do you have problems
with the internet?
No, it's my emulator.
EMILY FORTUNA: Oh.
So-- Oh, yeah.
Is there more stuff?
LARA MARTIN: This is just the--
EMILY FORTUNA: The
Android emulator itself?
LARA MARTIN: Yeah.
EMILY FORTUNA: So do you have
any experiences that you've
run into, in general,
developing Flutter,
where this has come in handy?
Do you remember any
particular thing?
LARA MARTIN: Yes.
When we were preparing
for our talk--
EMILY FORTUNA: Oh, yeah?
LARA MARTIN: --and we
wanted to show the WebViews,
I was interested to see how
Flutter was rendering WebViews.
So first, I was going
through the code,
trying to understand
how everything worked.
But it was difficult.
[LAUGHS] Too much code.
And so somehow, I thought, I'm
going to use the inspector.
And basically, I had like the
summary of the code there,
and I could see
already the widgets
that were being rendered.
EMILY FORTUNA: Cool.
LARA MARTIN: So that
was really nice.
EMILY FORTUNA: You
want to show us?
Just the WebView and widgets.
LARA MARTIN: Oh, yeah.
Sure.
So we can use this, maybe.
EMILY FORTUNA: For some
reason, that website
looks a little unhappy.
Let's try a different one.
LARA MARTIN: Yeah.
EMILY FORTUNA: A
different article.
So a little bit about under the
covers on WebViews on Android.
So actually, there's
a virtual display
that is-- so you've
got your Flutter,
and then there's
a virtual display
that is communicating with
the actual WebView layout.
And so that is what is
displaying the WebView.
And if you recall from
the last "Boring Show,"
we briefly put on a button
on top of the WebView
And if you wanted to--
So Flutter, when you
have a touch gesture,
the question is, does
that go to the WebView,
or does that go to Flutter?
How does that all work out?
And what happens
is Flutter captures
all the gestures
itself, and then if it
gets passed onto the WebView--
like if you were touching
in the WebView area--
then it will synthesize
those touches
on that virtual display.
So let's check it
out on the inspector.
LARA MARTIN: Yes.
I just saw this--
how do you call it?
EMILY FORTUNA: Search icon?
LARA MARTIN: Search icon.
That's fine.
EMILY FORTUNA: Magnifying glass?
LARA MARTIN: Yeah.
That's what I was looking for.
EMILY FORTUNA: OK.
[LAUGHS]
LARA MARTIN: But I don't
remember how, but basically,
when you enable the showing--
how it's called-- widget mode,
sometimes you see the icon.
So you can tap on things.
I'm not sure.
EMILY FORTUNA: Oh.
LARA MARTIN: I have
to look it up again.
EMILY FORTUNA: OK.
LARA MARTIN: Now I lost it.
EMILY FORTUNA: You click on--
LARA MARTIN: Yeah, so you--
EMILY FORTUNA:
Select a new thing.
LARA MARTIN: Yeah, exactly.
EMILY FORTUNA: I want to magnify
or look at a different thing.
Got it.
LARA MARTIN: So now, I
selected the WebView.
EMILY FORTUNA: That is
not showing anything.
LARA MARTIN: It is highlighted.
It's not showing anything.
Yeah, that's weird.
EMILY FORTUNA: I wonder--
try a different--
LARA MARTIN: Oh.
EMILY FORTUNA: That's because
we had the slow animations.
Try a different article,
see if it's better.
LARA MARTIN: No.
We saw it before.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yeah.
LARA MARTIN: OK.
EMILY FORTUNA:
Destroy all software.
LARA MARTIN: Everything
is so slow now.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yeah.
[LAUGHS] Nothing?
LARA MARTIN: Maybe it's
the internet today.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yeah.
I see a stack trace down
here, but I'm trying.
LARA MARTIN: Gonna check again.
EMILY FORTUNA:
Seems to be working.
Double value?
PlatformViews?
Uh-oh.
We got a bug to report.
LARA MARTIN: Uh-oh.
EMILY FORTUNA: All right, well--
LARA MARTIN: I don't
think I like this.
[LAUGHS]
EMILY FORTUNA: OK,
so this is not--
do you want to at least
click-- show us the inspector
and then--
LARA MARTIN: Yes.
EMILY FORTUNA: --we
can report this bug.
LARA MARTIN: Let's make
like this is working.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yes.
LARA MARTIN: Let's pretend.
EMILY FORTUNA: You didn't
se anything wrong here.
LARA MARTIN: So we have
selected the WebView.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yes.
LARA MARTIN: OK, now, we're
seeing the WebView on iOS.
I don't know how it works--
EMILY FORTUNA: Oh, oh.
LARA MARTIN: --on iOS.
EMILY FORTUNA: I
just had a thought.
That might actually be
part of the problem.
LARA MARTIN: Yeah.
Maybe.
Maybe that's the problem.
EMILY FORTUNA: So I know when
you're doing WebView on iOS,
in the info.plist--
this is from the
previous episode--
and you add a feature--
or, not a feature.
What am I saying?
You add a key value pair
that says enable WebViews.
And I suspect that this enable
iOS view on an Android thing
is making--
PlatformViews is a new feature.
It is not at 1.0 yet.
I imagine this is
making it very unhappy.
LARA MARTIN: Yes.
So that's why before, we
saw it, at some point.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yeah, yeah.
LARA MARTIN: I guess
it was with Android.
EMILY FORTUNA: I
think you're right.
LARA MARTIN: OK
Let's switch back.
Yay!
OK, we have it.
Cool.
Now, we see the tree for iOS.
I guess, if we don't refresh,
we will see it again.
EMILY FORTUNA: OK.
LARA MARTIN: We can select--
EMILY FORTUNA: The web view.
LARA MARTIN: --the Android.
OK, now--
EMILY FORTUNA: All is good.
LARA MARTIN: All is
good and working.
So basically, what I was doing
for preparing for our talk was
to go through this, like
how this is working,
and I saw this Android view.
I'm like, OK, what is this?
And I went to the source
to see what it was doing,
and basically--
I will close this.
And basically, here it showed--
yeah, it says embeds an Android
view in the widget hierarchy.
So it was very
explanatory and a cool way
to go through the code.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yeah.
That's awesome.
Very cool.
So yeah, basically sounds like
widget inspector is a great way
to--
number one, if you had
some weird layout thing
or if you want to be very
particular about your layouts,
and you were worried about your
pixels, your precious pixels.
LARA MARTIN: Yeah.
EMILY FORTUNA: And if you are
trying to understand a code
base, and figure out
where this thing goes
and how it is implemented.
Yeah.
Super cool.
LARA MARTIN: Yes.
EMILY FORTUNA: Thanks, Lara.
All right, so let's shift gears.
And we can go into implementing
the page scroll view.
Does that sounds good?
LARA MARTIN: OK.
EMILY FORTUNA: Cool.
OK.
LARA MARTIN: Let's see.
EMILY FORTUNA: So over on my
computer, so if you recall,
we've got this block where
we have our articles.
And right now, we've got
just one list of articles.
It's the the articlesSubject.
What we want to do instead--
so I mentioned this at the
end of the previous episode.
But the short version is--
let me ListView.
So right now, we have
this single StreamBuilder
with the ListView in it.
And when we click
on these two tabs,
we just toggle between
the two different--
we basically are
adding and removing
articles from a single ListView.
But that won't work
if we want to preserve
page scroll position, because
if there's only one ListView,
and you're moving in
different locations,
we want to have like two
different page scroll
locations.
So we're going to break this
stream out into two streams.
So we'll have a top stories
and a new stories stream.
So I think, let's call
this topArticleSubject
and newArticlesSubject.
And of course, if we
started having many tabs,
we might put this in
an array or something.
But I think--
LARA MARTIN: Yeah.
EMILY FORTUNA:
--two, that's fine.
LARA MARTIN: Good enough.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yes.
OK, so now, get articles.
We want to have two of these.
So get topArticles
and get newArticles--
topArticles, newArticles.
Great.
What else-- articlesSubjects.
OK.
LARA MARTIN: Now it's
more complicated.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yes.
[LAUGHS] All right.
So this gets called.
Let's see here.
LARA MARTIN: OK.
I'm going to check also--
EMILY FORTUNA: Look at this.
LARA MARTIN: --my
laptop, so I can--
EMILY FORTUNA: Yeah, please.
That's appreciated.
OK.
So what we do is, when
this block is constructed,
we set up a single listener,
and we set up a storiesType.
So instead-- let me look
at this stream controller.
Question is, do we want to
stream controllers or just one?
I would think just one,
but let's see here.
Yeah.
So we should be able to--
where is storiesType?
LARA MARTIN: To have only one?
EMILY FORTUNA: Yeah,
I think we should
be able to have two listeners.
Like listen twice, but to
the same controller, I think.
LARA MARTIN: We can try that.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yeah.
Let's see.
Because I think storiesType--
where is that declared?
LARA MARTIN: Oh, wasn't
it in the article?
No.
EMILY FORTUNA: StoriesType,
oh for god's sake.
LARA MARTIN: Yeah, I remember
doing this part, also myself,
watching the episode.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yeah.
LARA MARTIN: I don't remember
where it was declared.
EMILY FORTUNA: So it
looks like it's in getter.
And maybe we don't want
to have listen twice.
LARA MARTIN: OK,
the storiesType it's
an enum, and [INAUDIBLE]
in the [INAUDIBLE]??
EMILY FORTUNA: Yes.
Right.
So the question is--
OK, let's work backwards here.
So we have to getIds.
So where is getIds?
Basically, we want
to call getIds twice.
And one for top,
and one for new.
LARA MARTIN: Yes.
EMILY FORTUNA: So let's look
up where getIds is called.
Oh, of course.
In here.
So instead, let's just pass
in storiesType.newStories,
storiesType.topStories.
LARA MARTIN: This is because
you are listening in two places,
but for two different things.
So you here specify
which kind of story.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yes.
But I think-- so hold on.
GetArticles.
You may be saying this.
And I apologize if I'm not--
LARA MARTIN: No worries.
EMILY FORTUNA: I just need
to stare at this for a second
here.
OK, so we have our list--
oh, OK.
Yes.
This is maybe what
you're saying.
I apologize if you
just said this.
So I think we don't need
to have two separate--
I think we should be able
to just put it in here.
Because you listen for stories--
LARA MARTIN: Yeah.
EMILY FORTUNA: And when
there are new stories--
this is a little
bit inefficient.
We can come back and fix it.
But the next step--
which we can get to,
if we have time--
would be to listen for new
and top stories separately.
Right now, are saying,
if there are new stories,
we're going to update both.
But I think that's
fine, for now.
So, OK.
Initialize-- what
was that called?
GetArticlesAndUpdate.
And then we're going to say--
we want to probably pass
in here the subject.
Because this gets
called, once for the new,
and one for the top.
LARA MARTIN: Yeah.
EMILY FORTUNA: And
so we want to pass in
whether it's top or new--
LARA MARTIN: Yes.
EMILY FORTUNA: --to
add it to that stream.
That makes sense?
LARA MARTIN: Yeah.
EMILY FORTUNA: OK, so
what is the type of that?
It's like BehaviorSubject
[INAUDIBLE] Coffee.
[LAUGHS] Where'd that go?
Here it is.
Oh, wait.
No, up.
LARA MARTIN: No, up.
EMILY FORTUNA: Large
font size problems.
OK, subjects.
And then we say subjects.
LARA MARTIN: And
then [INAUDIBLE]
EMILY FORTUNA: It
used to be there.
LARA MARTIN: Why
is it complaining?
EMILY FORTUNA: That's
a good question.
LARA MARTIN: There's
something here [INAUDIBLE]??
EMILY FORTUNA: Oh, I'm
missing a-- there we go.
LARA MARTIN: Yeah.
OK.
EMILY FORTUNA:
That's much better.
And then we need to call
this with the new thing.
So getArticlesAndUpdate.
OK, we can come
back to that one.
This one, we say
topArticlesSubject.
Or, sorry.
It's in this one.
newArticlesSubject.
I typed away from myself.
LARA MARTIN: Maybe if you--
yeah.
It wasn't showing you, I
guess, that you called type
in newArticlesSubject.
You have these variable upper,
so it wasn't showing you
that you called you said
because you were typing
just next to await, I think.
EMILY FORTUNA: Oh, and it
wasn't auto-completing.
LARA MARTIN: Yep.
EMILY FORTUNA: Got it.
OK, and so then
here, initialize--
we probably want to call
getArticlesAndUpdate
twice again.
So let's just--
LARA MARTIN: Twice?
EMILY FORTUNA: Well, one's--
LARA MARTIN: Yeah, yeah.
EMILY FORTUNA: --for top,
and one's for new, right?
Because this is just
getting the things
established, and
we want them both--
I mean, I guess, technically--
LARA MARTIN: It's fine.
It's OK.
EMILY FORTUNA: There will be an
efficiency re-editing session
after this.
LARA MARTIN: We can
always do it refactor.
EMILY FORTUNA: That looks great.
LARA MARTIN: Oh, OK.
EMILY FORTUNA: What do we do?
Well, part of it,
I imagine we're
going to need a hot
restart, because I redefined
a bunch of new variables.
LARA MARTIN: For sure.
EMILY FORTUNA: So
let's start with that.
That still looks great.
LARA MARTIN: Oh, it
cannot find articles,
because you changed the name.
EMILY FORTUNA: Right.
OK, so let's look in here.
OK, so we need to have
two StreamBuilders.
Yes.
All right.
OK, we have this
currentIndex, and we
want to display a different
StreamBuilder, aka ListView,
depending on the index.
And because there's
only two, I'm
going to do the little ternary--
LARA MARTIN: Of course.
EMILY FORTUNA: --thing.
And then we're going
do refactoring,
because this is going to
become unreadable very quickly.
So let's see.
The current index is 0.
We're going to do one thing.
Oh my gosh.
This makes me sad.
I promise, we're
refactoring soon.
LARA MARTIN: But it's a
good way to understanding
what you're doing.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yes.
LARA MARTIN: And then you can
refactor it, and it gets nicer.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yes.
All right.
So let me just make
sure, 0 is top.
LARA MARTIN: Yes.
And 1 is news stories.
Yes.
EMILY FORTUNA:
Articles, newArticles.
LARA MARTIN: OK.
EMILY FORTUNA: Now what?
Oh, it looks like we have
another article statement here
somewhere.
Oh, here we go.
Oh, this is the search.
I have not spent enough
time with this part.
LARA MARTIN: You
implemented search?
I didn't watch the--
EMILY FORTUNA: Somebody did.
I have it.
LARA MARTIN: Oh, the last one.
OK.
EMILY FORTUNA:
Let's start with--
[INAUDIBLE]
LARA MARTIN: Oh, yeah.
I see it.
EMILY FORTUNA: So showSearch.
LARA MARTIN: That's
cause we opened before
with the inspector and
we didn't understand.
EMILY FORTUNA: Oh.
LARA MARTIN: [INAUDIBLE]
EMILY FORTUNA: You know,
that keeps messing me up,
the search thing.
It messed me up in the
previous episode, too.
LARA MARTIN: OK, that's it.
EMILY FORTUNA: And this
is why I was like, we
need to refactor stuff.
I'm going to comment
this out, for a minute,
and we're just going to see
if our other stuff works.
And then come back to it.
All right.
And if we go to news--
OK.
All right.
So we're showing different
things, that's great.
LARA MARTIN: It works.
EMILY FORTUNA: Let's add in
the scroll position thing.
LARA MARTIN: Oh, sure.
EMILY FORTUNA: And then we
can come back to search.
Does that sound good?
LARA MARTIN: Yes, yes.
EMILY FORTUNA: OK, cool.
So adding scroll is
going to be real easy.
There's this page
storage key, which
I'm going to look
up for a hot second.
LARA MARTIN: Oh, yeah.
We were talking about
these yesterday, right?
EMILY FORTUNA: Oh,
keys in general.
LARA MARTIN: Yeah.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yeah.
Oh, a couple things.
So there's a lot of things
that we just did here.
So the original reason that
there were keys in these--
keys in these-- is when
we switch from one view
to another.
Again, before, we were
adding or removing
from the same ListView.
And now, we have
two separate ones.
So keys would probably
not be necessary, except--
because we still
have these WebViews--
I think if we removed the
keys and you tried to open it,
it would think it was the same--
it would display the wrong page.
So we keep that there.
We can test that in a minute.
But back to page storage.
So I can't remember
if it's a global key
or not that you put in.
Oh, no, it looks
like it's just--
LARA MARTIN: Page
storage key class?
EMILY FORTUNA: Yeah.
LARA MARTIN: OK.
EMILY FORTUNA: So I
believe we're just going
to put it in the ListView.
So key-- PageStorageKey().
And then we'll use the
index, which I guess--
[INAUDIBLE] coding.
LARA MARTIN: It works for now.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yeah.
Best development practices ever.
Oh wait, don't do that.
OK.
So fingers crossed.
Now, let's scroll
here a little bit.
OK, and then we switch.
And now, let's see if we're--
Oh.
Wow.
That's exciting.
[LAUGHS]
LARA MARTIN: No such method.
EMILY FORTUNA: Line
indexOf(child) index
[INAUDIBLE].
Huh?
Whoo.
[LAUGHS] I'm just going
to start fresh here.
Hot restart.
I don't think
that's the problem.
LARA MARTIN:
Sometimes I do that.
I run--
EMILY FORTUNA: What am I doing?
LARA MARTIN: --and
it doesn't work.
And I run it again,
just in case.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yeah.
LARA MARTIN: And then I'm
sure it's not working,
and I [INAUDIBLE]
EMILY FORTUNA: Yeah.
It's like, maybe this
is not my problem.
OK, clear console.
We're in new stories.
Technology's dark forest
is at the top here.
Switch.
Cool.
Oh.
And here, I was going to say,
adding page scroll position is
so easy.
Oh, boy.
OK.
Double is not a subtype of bool.
What?
[INAUDIBLE]
LARA MARTIN: Do you have to
define the type with a page
storage key, maybe?
EMILY FORTUNA: Maybe.
It looks like it's inferring it.
Let's see inferring
slivers, why is it unhappy--
scroll offset correction
is called on--
LARA MARTIN: And
there's the [INAUDIBLE]
EMILY FORTUNA: It
was ExpansionTile.
LARA MARTIN: This was the
stack, ExpansionTileState.
EMILY FORTUNA: InitState.
I'm wondering if
there's something
strange with PageStorage and
Expansion tiles, like maybe,
because they expand--
LARA MARTIN: They expand, yeah.
EMILY FORTUNA: --it
confuses the location?
Let me try.
I'm going to try it,
again, to like debug this.
Instead of having an
ExpansionTile here,
maybe we have something
really simple, like just text.
LARA MARTIN: Just to try out.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yeah.
So here's my really silly thing.
I just returned twice.
So return text HELP.
OK, let's restart,
because it's crashed,
so it's unhappy with us.
LARA MARTIN: Why do you
have two return statements?
Can you?
EMILY FORTUNA: What do you mean?
Yeah, yeah.
That works.
LARA MARTIN: OK.
EMILY FORTUNA: Oh,
this isn't going
to be very useful for scrolling.
OK, I'll put it in a ListTile.
Wrap with new widget.
ListTile, text.
Wait, ListTile is--
what am I doing?
I've been switching
between editors too much.
Can't even remember.
LARA MARTIN: That's true.
EMILY FORTUNA:
Command-Function-F12.
Whoops.
That's not it.
F12.
There we go.
ListTile.
Title, there we go.
Title.
Close that.
LARA MARTIN: OK, you need--
EMILY FORTUNA: Help, help, help.
OK, I still can't scroll.
I'm going to-- oh my gosh.
Let's wrap it in padding.
[LAUGHS] And we'll make
the padding huge, like 50.
OK.
Now, of course, the
question is, if we scroll,
is it going to really know?
But we can see the offset.
OK.
So I scrolled here, and it's
going to be like part-way down.
LARA MARTIN: Yeah.
EMILY FORTUNA: Right.
So we switched to here,
I've got more help.
LARA MARTIN: That works.
EMILY FORTUNA: And let
me, again, just test.
OK.
So it preserves scroll position.
So it's something
with ExpansionTile.
LARA MARTIN: Yeah.
Maybe I will search.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yeah.
LARA MARTIN: PageStorageKey
with ExpansionTile?
EMILY FORTUNA: Yeah.
Yes, yes, yes.
LARA MARTIN: OK.
ExpansionTile class,
PageStorageKey.
A unique PageStorageKey
must be specified
to enable the ExpansionTile
to save and restore
its expanded state.
EMILY FORTUNA: Oh, boy.
Wow.
Wait, when used a unique--
Oh, so we have keys,
but not PageStorageKeys.
That's maybe the problem.
Let's try that.
PageStorage--
LARA MARTIN: Oh, yeah.
EMILY FORTUNA: Oh, storage.
That would help if I could type.
OK.
Let's try this.
I'm a little skeptical.
OK, so we scroll up.
Technology's dark forest.
LARA MARTIN: It works.
EMILY FORTUNA: When all else
fails, read the documentation.
OK.
Yay.
Cool.
So yeah. so generally, when
you don't have ExpansionTiles,
you only need one
PageStorageKey.
But with ExpansionTiles, since
there's multiple scrolling
things going on, you need two.
Cool.
OK.
Oh, and let me just check
now that with PageStorageKey,
the WebView thing--
why is that not showing?
OK.
LARA MARTIN: OK.
EMILY FORTUNA: So I
just want to make sure
that when we go here--
LARA MARTIN: It's there.
EMILY FORTUNA: --that
the right WebViews--
OK.
This is good.
Cool.
And we'll just pretend
that that website's broken.
LARA MARTIN: So it works.
EMILY FORTUNA: It does.
LARA MARTIN: Yeah.
EMILY FORTUNA: So we can
do a little bit of cleanup
with my hackiness.
LARA MARTIN: Yes.
EMILY FORTUNA: And let
me get rid of-- why
do I have-- there, OK.
All right.
Oh, yes.
So first, let me uncomment
the search thing,
and we're going to figure out
what to do with this business.
So let us read about--
LARA MARTIN: That's below.
There was one more thing.
EMILY FORTUNA: I
know, but this--
LARA MARTIN:
[INAUDIBLE] different.
EMILY FORTUNA: --was
already commented.
OK.
This is part of refactoring.
Gone.
OK.
[LAUGHS] So let's see
what's going on here.
People that watch the
other episodes are
like, why didn't you read this?
LARA MARTIN: I was
waiting for you to fix it.
It's fixed now.
EMILY FORTUNA: OK.
So we have a builder,
and we have a button.
So, OK.
It's this thing.
LARA MARTIN: Yeah.
EMILY FORTUNA: Oh,
and it's not running.
So when it's pressed,
we have this showSearch
and we delegate.
So let's look at showSearch.
ShowSearch, which is
a hard thing to say.
Oh, is this built in?
No, we added it.
Wow.
Did we have all these comments?
Good job, whoever did that.
OK.
SearchDelegate, what
does SearchDelegate do?
LARA MARTIN: This is part
of the search [INAUDIBLE]
EMILY FORTUNA: Oh, OK.
So we did it.
I was like, wow.
LARA MARTIN: It's a lot.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yeah, I know.
OK, so let's just look
at the documentation,
because that's easier.
Flutter material search.
That's a package.
But there is documentation here.
API reference.
OK, material_search.
LARA MARTIN: I never implemented
a search function feature
myself, so this is
interesting to see.
EMILY FORTUNA: Is
this from materials?
LARA MARTIN: It seems
like it's from material.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yeah, so is it
maybe not this package though?
Because this is--
LARA MARTIN: But we can
search on Flutter directly
for materials.dart and
search store Dart maybe.
EMILY FORTUNA: showSearch.
Here we go.
OK, yeah, it's not the package.
I just want to read what
this delegate thing is doing.
LARA MARTIN: [INAUDIBLE]
EMILY FORTUNA: [INAUDIBLE] OK.
So in that case, we'll do
a little ternary thing,
and say like newArticles
or topArticles,
because we want to search
whatever is in the current set.
OK.
So we're going to look up--
oh, currentIndex.
OK, so we're going to say
currentIndex equals 0.
I believe that's topArticles.
LARA MARTIN: It was top, yes.
EMILY FORTUNA: TopArticles
or widget.bloc.newArticles.
OK.
So now, should be able
to search on Dark.
LARA MARTIN: So you're basically
just searching [INAUDIBLE]??
EMILY FORTUNA: Which technically
was the same functionality
before, because remember, it was
adding and removing articles.
And actually, now that I've
done this, I'm wondering--
we may not have time to do this
part, but I'm wondering if we--
PageStorageKey.
In a future episode,
we'll have to explore--
I think PageStorageKey
doesn't like
when we were adding or removing
from this single thing,
because if you
switch tabs, it will
have the other scroll position.
Yeah, OK.
Never mind.
No, I think there's
no way you get around.
We had to have two
streams for this.
LARA MARTIN: Yeah.
Yeah.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yep.
OK.
Cool.
Well, I think this is
a good stopping point.
Unless there's any quick
little clean up we can do,
because I do admit, we
kind of made this messy.
LARA MARTIN: Duplicated
things sometimes.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yes.
LARA MARTIN: You want to check.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yeah.
OK, it says-- are we
using this anymore?
TopArticlesSubject.
LARA MARTIN: No, because
you're using directly
to the [INAUDIBLE]?
EMILY FORTUNA: But
why is this green?
LARA MARTIN: Can
you hover on top?
EMILY FORTUNA: It's trying to--
problems.
Close.
Is this it?
Close this.
Yeah, OK.
So we need to close.
So it's like destroy.
Oh, why did that come up?
That's a good question.
So normally with widgets,
you've got your init state,
and then you can--
it's either dispose or destroy.
I think it's dispose.
I get mixed--
LARA MARTIN: Yeah, it's dispose.
EMILY FORTUNA: --up with C++.
LARA MARTIN: I'm
thinking of Java.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yeah.
I'm pretty sure it's dispose.
You close.
But then it was Block,
because it's not a widget,
and it doesn't
have the lifecycle.
It's standing alone.
We don't have that same thing.
So I'm not quite
sure what the best
practice is for doing that.
LARA MARTIN: I
know, on Avex, you
have to clear the
disposable at the end.
EMILY FORTUNA: So maybe at the
end of our main or something,
you would say like
hnBlock.clear--
LARA MARTIN: Clear.
EMILY FORTUNA: --or something.
LARA MARTIN: Yeah.
Something.
EMILY FORTUNA: OK, let's--
LARA MARTIN: Because if you are
navigating to another place,
and you don't need those
subscriptions anymore,
then you have to clear them.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yeah.
OK.
I'm going to leave that.
I will look to
verify that that's
how we want to do it for Block,
because Filip is the Block
expert, [INAUDIBLE].
LARA MARTIN: OK.
That's cool.
EMILY FORTUNA: But I
tentatively will say, yeah.
I think you add it
at the very end.
LARA MARTIN: And you can
write a to-do for Filip.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yes.
There you go.
To-do-- filiph.
Do we close-- because I write
all my things in caps here--
Block subscriptions here?
All right, perfect.
So thank you for
being with us today.
In summary, we talked about
the Flutter Inspector,
and I learned a whole lot.
That was super cool.
Thank you, Lara.
LARA MARTIN: Thank you.
EMILY FORTUNA: And then
we added PageStorageKey
for preserving scroll position.
I added more of a
mess to our code,
so the refactoring
is still to come.
And we also learned that,
if you have ExpansionTile
and PageStorageKey, you need
to have another PageStorageKey,
because that's growing there
and preserving position
with the overall ListView.
So cool.
Thanks for watching
in, and please
feel free to ask
questions in the comments.
And yeah.
Lara, it's been great.
LARA MARTIN: Thank
you for inviting me.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yeah.
LARA MARTIN: It's been fun.
EMILY FORTUNA: Excellent.
Until next time.
LARA MARTIN: Bye-bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]